[Musik]
bevor du dir dieses video ansieht muss
ich dich warm was du sehen und hören
wirst kann deine gefühle verletzen und
ein starkes gefühl der empörung
hervorrufen wir werden dir überein
königshaus berichten welches wohl
weltweit in sachen despotie und
dekadenten verhalten seines gleichen
sucht wir werden darüber sprechen wie
ein sultan sein volk schamlos aus bord
ins mittelalter wird und menschen die
behandelt
nein dieses video enthält wahrlich keine
werbung eher das gegenteil davon bist du
bereit dann lasst uns loslegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn ich dich bitte an ein land in
südostasien zu denken mit ausnahme von
singapur das ein ähnliches pro kopf
bruttoinlandsprodukt hat die spanien
oder südkorea an welches land würdest du
denken na
321 ich bin mir sicher dass nur sehr
wenige von euch an partei gedacht hätten
also wenn du nicht schon den titel
dieses videos gelesen hättest und es ist
sehr wahrscheinlich dass die große
mehrheit von euch kaum etwas von diesen
kleinen land gehört hat dass er mehr auf
der insel borneo liegt und an land von
malaysia umgeben ist verona ist nicht
nur vom territorium herr klein sondern
auch von der einwohnerzahl das land das
offiziell als staat brunei darussalam
bekannt ist es ist kaum eine halbe
million einwohner
trotzdem sprechen wir über eines der
länder mit dem höchsten pro kopf
vermögen der welt wieso nun die erdöl-
und erdgasvorkommen sind relativ groß
und sultan hassanal bolkiah konnte sich
diese zu nutze machen mit der förderung
und verarbeitung von erdöl und
flüssigerdgas erwirtschaftet die kleine
nation mehr als die hälfte ihres produkt
in das produkt darüber hinaus werden die
meisten dieser ressourcen in seiner
exklusiven wirtschaftszone auf dem meer
gewonnen deswegen brunei über eine der
weltweit am besten erhaltenen
natürlichen landschaften verfügung
soweit klingt das alles doch wunder hat
rechtlich nicht wahr wie ein paradies
auf erden nur warte ein moment denn du
weißt ja dass nicht alles gold ist was
glänzt und dieses sprichwort trifft im
falle drohen eis den nagel auf den kopf
[Applaus]
obwohl es sich um ein so reiches land
handelt genießen die pro neuer nur ein
recht durchschnittlichen lebensstandard
und wenn es um freiheit oder
menschenrechte geht dann ist die bilanz
dieses asiatischen landes nicht nur
schlecht sondern sie wird immer
schlechter aber nachdem ich das gesagt
habe bin ich mir sicher dass du schon
einfach fragen hast wenn dieses sultanat
scheinbar so erreicht ist was passiert
dann mit all dem geld das die bürger
brunei ist nicht zu sehen bekommen was
passiert politisch im land so dass
anders als im rest der welt die
bürgerrechte tatsächlich im niedergang
begriffen sind nun in diesem video
werden wir diese zwei fragen beantworten
und wir werden euch so einige dinge über
die extremen spleens und die totalitären
neigungen des aktuellen sultans erzählen
bist du bereit dazu nun dann lasst uns
schnell nach brunei reisen
[Musik]
das verschwenderische sultanat
was du als nächstes sein wirst ist eine
geschichte die komplett aus einem
hollywood film voller klischees kommen
könnte du weißt schon eine dieser
geschichten über reichen
ölscheichs die sich mit dem
extravagantesten luxus umgeben den man
sich vorstellen kann und die sogar einen
harem von frauen ganz für sich allein
haben nun das ist nicht allzu weit davon
entfernt so was das aktuelle königshaus
von brunei geworden ist ein königshaus
das nicht nur gerne dinge besitzt
sondern sie auch gerne zur schau stellt
sind zb die 14 millionen dollar teure
goldene rolls royce limousine die sultan
hassanal gehört und nein das ist nicht
das einzige teure auto in seiner garage
nicht im entferntesten tatsächlich wird
geschätzt aus dem königshaus mehr als
7000 fahrzeuge zur verfügung stehen wir
sprechen von einem fuhrpark mit einem
geschätzten wert von etwa fünf
milliarden dollar allein für autos ja
das hast du richtig gehört 5 milliarden
dollar für autos
natürlich sprechen wir über einen sultan
dessen vermögen auf mehr als 20
milliarden dollar geschätzt wird um die
eine vorstellung zu geben diese zahl ist
viel höher als das gesamte
bruttoinlandsprodukt des landes wenn wir
berücksichtigen dass das
bruttoinlandsprodukt ronis etwa 13 5
milliarden dollar beträgt bedeutet es
dass das vermögen des sultans um fast 50
prozent größer ist das ist so als wenn
die britische königsfamilie ein vermögen
von fast vier billionen pfund hätte mehr
als das gesamte bip deutschlands also
einfach verrückt
tatsache ist dass sich unter dem im
mindesten inventar dass das vermögen des
tages ausmacht 10 luxusyachten
mindestens 17 flugzeuge und mehr als 150
willen in zwölf verschiedenen ländern
befinden und das ist noch nicht alles
als ob dieses riesige vermögen der ganze
prunk und luxus nicht schon genug wäre
liegt dieser sultan auch noch im größten
privatpalast der welt ein palast dann
nicht weniger als 1700 88 zimmer 257
bäder 15 impuls eine eigene moschee und
eine garage für 110 seiner autos hat
neben vielen anderen luxus features zum
beispiel ist der gesamte palast mit 38
arten von italienischem marmor shanghai
granit englischen kristallglas und
indischen seinen verzierungen
ausgekleidet mit anderen worten wir
reden hier von einem typen der einfach
nicht mit luxus geist und die dies alles
mal zu veranschaulichen während seiner
wildesten tage als er noch etwas immer
wahr wird geschätzt dass die sultan zehn
jahre lang fast
750.000 dollar pro tag aber es gab das
muss schon ganz schön anstrengend sein
natürlich geht es nicht nur darum mit
diesem ganzen luxus zu posten die das
sultan hat auch eine geschäftliche seite
zum beispiel besitzt er seine eigene
hotelkette nun technisch gesehen ist
diese kette die deutscheste collection
im besitz des nationalen staatsfonds von
brunei eines forster wiederum vom
finanzministerium abhängt das jedoch
überraschung sondern zustand hassanal
selbst geleitet wird aber nehmen wir der
einfachheit halber mal an das ist in
frohnau gar keinen unterschied zwischen
öffentlichem vermögen und den des
königshauses gibt oder besser gesagt
dass in diesem sultanat das öffentliche
vermögen dem königshaus gehört
natürlich genießt nicht nur das schuld
an diesen immensen reichtum sondern auch
seine gesamte familie die übrigens auch
nicht davor zurückschreckt diesen
reichtum in den sozialen netzwerken zur
schau zu stellen in der tat ist sein
zehntes kind ein ziemlicher instagram
star mit mehr als zwei millionen
follower auf dieser asozial plattform
hält sich der junge martin gerade mal 29
jahre alt alles andere als zurück wenn
es darum geht seine helikopterflüge
seine fallschirmsprünge seien jetzt in
seine liebe zum polo oder seiner reise
um die welt natürlich im eigenen
privatjet instagram gerechtes zur schau
zu stellen aber eines muss man ihnen
lassen diese wahnsinnig produktiven
menschen sind aber auch sowas
konstruktiv geradezu super produktiv
mein lieber scholli was die alles ihren
alltag packen können ich wäre da schon
nach kurzer zeit fix und fertig gut aber
du weißt ist visuell politik keine promi
show mit klatsch und tratsch wenn wir
die all diese dinge erzählen dann nur um
uns selbst mental vorzubereiten auf das
was jetzt kommt dann behalte eines im
hinterkopf bruni ist nicht irgendein
land und seine schultern ist es auch
nicht
[Musik]
was an adel gilt als einer der letzten
absolutistischen monarchie des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts und ist
der am zweitlängsten regierende monarch
übertroffen nur von der aktuellen
königin von england
[Musik]
um genau zu sein es ist seit 1967 auf
dem thron und beachte dass er nicht nur
der sultan ist sondern auch die position
des premierministers des
verteidigungsministers des
finanzministers und des außenministers
inne hat und wer weiß vielleicht hat er
sich während der entstehung dieses video
schon wieder selbst die leitung eines
weiteren ressorts übertragen also ja die
regierung besteht im grunde aus kannst
du dir interessen der exekutive
vorstellen alles ist das sicher ein
permanenter konsens zwischen dem
verteidigungsministerium dem
finanzministerium und dem
außenministerium außer hassanal malische
so fred ist ein müssen wir uns die
kabinettssitzungen aber sturms
langweilig vorstellen kurz gesagt pass
an alle ist ein beispiel dafür wie
absolutistische macht aussieht gut an
diesem punkt denken sicher viele von
euch okay dieser mann muss der typische
despot sein der sich nachts in dollar
schein welt werden sein volk hungert
richtig nur die wahrheit ist nein
zumindest nicht ganz
[Musik]
das in brunei entwickelte
wirtschaftssystem ist alles andere als
typisch brunei ist die lehrbuch
definition einer wohlfahrts renten
ökonomie was mich das erklären das
königshaus von roma erkauft sich die
realität und das schweigen des volkes im
austausch für bestimmte leistungen die
natürlich kleinigkeiten darstellen im
vergleich zum potenziellen reichtum die
seine bürger in anbetracht der immensen
reichtümer des landes genießen sollten
stellt sich die frage wie kommen die
dortigen räume ist damit nur durch
nun schon bald im grunde verwendet die
regierung von brunei einen kleinen teil
ihrer öl und gas einnahmen um
sicherzustellen dass es tieren 460.000
einwohnern nicht an grundversorgung
mangelt um den rest behalten sie einfach
für sich auf diese weise können sie
weiterhin die wörter leben ohne zu
riskieren dass das volk aufgrund von
hunger oder abend ging es rebelliert
wurde gar das unethische verhalten ihrer
anführer in frage stellt und zu diesem
zweck geben sie den bürgern ein wenig
zucker brot und eine schwere zeit denn
wenn es eine sache gibt die in gronau
ausdrücklich vor allem anderen verboten
ist dann ist es schlecht über die
königliche familie zu sprechen und sich
vorsichtig denn wenn wir sagen dass die
bürger von brunei eine grundversorgung
erhalten nein wenn damit zum beispiel
auch ein haus und ein auto beides wird
mit krediten zu sehr niedrigen zinsen
subventionierte außerdem erhalten sie
kostenlose gesundheits und zahnpflege
kostenlose bildung und altersrenten
obendrein sogar beerdigungen werden von
der regierung subventioniert natürlich
sollte man sich nicht täuschen lassen
und denken dass das gesundheits und
bildungswesen von hoher qualität sein
zuschauer bürger könnten ihr aufmucken
die regierung verteilt das geld nichts
mit der gießkanne vielmehr schafft sie
anreize je mehr geld man hat desto mehr
bekommt er noch und auch wenn diese
ganze beschreibung technisch nicht ganz
korrekt ist in der praxis funktioniert
ist genauso
[Musik]
wir sprechen von einem land in dem die
bürger in hohem maße von den
staatseinnahmen abhängig geworden sind
und damit von dem was das sultaninen
geben will und dieser lässt den
lebensstandard seiner bürger weit unter
dem entwickelt dann ändern so viel
umsonst ist einfach nicht geben und das
gilt auch für freiheit menschenrechte
und soziale mobilität wenn du also nicht
das glück hattest in die wohlhabende
oberschicht hinein geboren zu werden die
enge beziehungen zum königshaus blickt
pech gehabt und das erklärte
schlagzeilen wie diese aus dem jahr 2019
die hohe kommissarin der vereinten
nationen für menschenrechte wagens neues
strafgesetz punkt würde grausame und
unmenschliche strafen festschreiben aber
was um alles in der welt wo er vor sich
so dass selbst die ohne die
normalerweise in politischen fragen
wegschaut aufspringt und alle
alarmglocken läuten lässt und was für
schwere taten handelt es sich dass das
sultanat beschlossen hat sie auf
grausame und unmenschliche weise zu
bestrafen nun aufgepasst
islamismus laster und heuchelei
ist mehrheitlich islamischen land etwa
drei seiner vier einwohner sind moslems
der rest ist eine mischung aus
christlichem buddhistischen und
indigenen glauben doch trotz der
tatsache dass jeder vierte mensch kein
muslim ist hat das land seit 2014
reformen und strafen aus dem islamischen
recht der scharia ins strafgesetzbuch
aufgenommen diese idee kam sultan
hassanal ende der 90er jahre und die
meisten seine bürger fragten sich gar
nicht so schlecht wohl wenn man bedenkt
wie die dinge hier laufen sieht es nicht
so aus als ob ihre meinung wirklich so
wichtig gewesen wäre die reformen mit
deren umsetzung 2014 begonnen wurde
wurde im april 2009 10 abgeschlossen so
und jetzt haltet euch besser fest
die neue strafgesetze legen zum beispiel
fest dass auf einvernehmliche sexuelle
beziehungen zwischen männern die
todesstrafe durch steinigung steht und
solche zwischen frauen mit bis zu 40
peitschenhieben oder bis zu zehn jahren
gefängnis bestraft werden
die gliedmaßen amputiert beginnt mit der
rechten hand wenn sie wieder straffällig
werden kommt der linke fuß an die reihe
und so weiter und so fort mit anderen
worten das ganze läuft auf die strikt
einführung der scharia im ganzen land
hinaus zurück ins mittelalter und jetzt
müssen sie das eines war gegenwärtigen
in der region über die die hier sprechen
ist dies ein absoluter anachronismus
keine muslimisches nachbarland hat auch
noch annähernd und menschliche kapital
strafen für diese art von tagen
auf diese weise ist das einzige land in
südostasien geworden dass eine wirklich
strenge vision des islamischen rechts im
stile von afghanistan saudi-arabien oder
den iran durchsetzen
[Musik]
es war zögert noch mit der vollstreckung
bis heute hat es in keinem dieser fälle
die todesstrafe angewandt und
tatsächlich hat es seit 1957 als das
land auch ein britisches protektorat war
niemand mehr hingerichtet aber die
tatsache dass sie die scharia in ihr
strafgesetzbuch aufgenommen haben
sondern eine gefährliche warnung aus die
macht des sultans steht über allem und
er wird weiterhin der garant für die
einheit des islam und die anwendung
seines gesetzes in seiner
fundamentalistischen version sagen aber
warte mal einen moment angesichts all
dieser regeln denken sicher viele von
euch okay wenn der sultan dem islam so
zugetan ist dann sollte auch so leben
wie ist die islamische tradition
vorschreibt oder nun nicht wirklich in
der tat scheint er genau das gegenteil
zu tun nicht nur weil sein luxuriöser
lebensstil und sei zur schau gestellter
reichtum der demut die der islam
verkündet zuwider laufen sondern auch
wegen seines persönlichen verhaltens
denn sowohl hasan als auch sein bruder
chef rief legen einen lebensstil der
soll ich sagen ein wenig umstritten ist
naja eigentlich ist er derart kontrovers
dass die beiden in der ganzen welt
berüchtigt sind
es gibt zum beispiel sehr viele frauen
die behauptet haben teil einer art
persönlichen harems des zweiten bruders
gewesen zu sein zu dutzenden seien sie
innerhalb des palast geländes
untergebracht beziehungsweise eigentlich
eher halb eingesperrt gewesen ohne
wirkliche möglichkeit mit der außenwelt
kommunizieren zu können und der sultan
selbst sollte diese frauen bei vielen
gelegenheiten auch genutzt haben ja das
klingt nicht besonders schön und ist es
auch nicht die rolle eines dieser
ehemaligen haares mädchen hat über ihre
erfahrungen im palast ein buch
geschrieben some girls my life in die
haare darin berichtet sie wie die
mädchen nach belieben benutzt und
entsorgt werden sie haben mehr geld als
jeder andere ich weiß dass die beide der
sultan jeffrey schon mehrfach
verheiratet und geschieden waren das ist
wirklich heuchlerisch und in der tat sie
hat recht während der sultan von brunei
für ehebruch die todesstrafe durch
steinigung verhängt hat veranstaltet er
und sein bruder seit jahren wilde
sexpartys mit dutzenden jahrhunderten
von frauen aus dem westen tatsächlich
gegen eine andere frau shannon markt
tätig mit united states 1992 soweit den
sultan vor einem gericht in den
vereinigten staaten an zu zeigen welches
die klage jedoch aufgrund seiner
diplomatischen immunität als
staatsoberhaupt ab wie es der fall trug
jedoch dass dubai ihre geschichte
berühmt zu machen denn der sich zum
beispiel darüber berichtet dass sie
unter dem vorwand eines seriösen model
in unserem haus für 3000 dollar am tag
nach brunei gelockt dort dann jedoch mit
drogen vollgepumpt wurde und schließlich
sowohl den schultern als aus seinem
bruder einen monat lang als sexsklavin
dienen musste
[Musik]
aber glaubt nicht eine sekunde lang dass
diese beiden charaktere die einzigen
partygänger sind die in skandale
verwickelt sind die skandale die fast
immer mit sagen wir mal und ethischer
geldverschwendung enden ein anderer
bruder des sultans mohammed kia der
angebliche us analyse und jeffries
verschwendungssucht verabscheute erhielt
eine abfindung in höhe von zwei
milliarden dollar damit der 2015 als
außen- und handelsminister abtritt aber
wer wird seinen ekel nicht für zwei
milliarden dollar beiseite schieben
können tatsache ist dass die opulenz der
königlichen familie und ihr verhalten
dass die lehren des islam vollkommen
missachtet sie wahrscheinlich zu einer
der häufigsten regierungen auf der
internationalen bühne heute gemacht hat
und das ist das moderne brunei soziale
stagnation aufgrund des emanzipierten
feindlichen wohlfahrts rundum
versorgungsmodell verletzung
grundlegender menschenrechte und eine
königsfamilie die in reichtum laster und
heuchelei badet aber jetzt bist du an
der reihe was hältst du von diesem
merkwürdigen system in dem
freiheitsfeindliche gesetze auf die
bürger angewandt werden aber nicht auf
das königshaus lässt du auch andere
beispiele in denen die herrschenden sich
über jene gesetze stellen welche sie dem
einfachen volk aufoktroyieren wird bruni
in der lage sein sich weiter zu
entwickeln während ein so großer teil
der rohstoffe oder direkt an das
königshaus geht wie immer sind wir auf
eure meinungen zu diesem thema
hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe also dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat falls ja
geht es mit einem leicht vergisst nicht
das abo und teilt ist auch mit euren
freunden macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]